remember the best tennis player of all
time Novak jokovic uh when he shut down
a reporter over his decision not to get
the CO jab it's worth noting in the in
the face of that Bill Gates nonsense
let's throw back to that one I
understand the consequences of my
decision and one of the consequences of
my decision was not going to Australia
and I was prepared not to go and I
understand that not being vaccinated
today I you know I'm unable to travel to
most of the tournaments at the moment
and that's the price you're willing to
pay that that is the price that I'm
willing to Pi
ultimately are you prepared to
forego the chance to be the greatest
player that ever picked up a racket
statistically because you feel so
strongly about this
jab
yes I do but as things stand if this
means that you miss miss the French Open
is that a price you'd be willing to pay
yes that is the price that I'm willing
to pay and if it means that you miss
Wimbledon this year again that's a price
you're willing to pay
yes why noac why why because the
principles of uh decision making on my
body uh are more important than any
title or anything else I'm I'm I'm
trying to be in tune with my body isn't
that so great when you have the truth on
why why why won't you get that injection
why won't you show up to it's my body
I'm going to do what I think is right
now the reason I'm showing you that is
because this past weekend Novak jokovic
was at the Aussie open and listen to
this there's a man you're going to hear
it screaming get vaccinated uh while
he's about to serve uh you might enjoy
this
one full match points
please
[Applause]
[Music]
6 how absolutely great is that like how
great is that get vaccinated the crowd's
not with that guy anymore the crowd
loves novic jokovic now and then just
freaking blows it by just absolute
straight up just blows it by the
opponent that's what it's all about
standing up for what you believe and
doing what you think is right living in
a way that is congruent with what your
brain knows and what we've known for
years and years and years as opposed to
being the to these people who would
gladly jail
you